rodney we spent some time talking about
the colts this year and who would have
ever dreamed last year at this time that
phillip rivers would be the starting
quarterback i mean andrew luck
supposedly had another 10 years or more
now it's a guy who's been around since
2004. you never played with him in san
diego with the charges drew brees was
the quarterback when you were there but
you played against philip rivers you
know what it's like to face him you've
watched his career the big question i
have is which phillip rivers still
exists is it the guy last year that had
so many struggles and had seven
interceptions in back-to-back prime time
games or is it the guy we saw earlier in
the career
what what what do you think after
watching philip rivers especially in
recent years what do you think he's
still got left as he heads to
indianapolis i think first and foremost
i think he needed a change mike i just
think he needed a change of environment
change of atmosphere you look at all his
struggles last year a lot of it was
offensive line a lot of him running for
his life forcing the ball down the field
trying to make something happen and you
just saw the frustration the consistent
frustration of philip rivers now he's
behind one of the best offensive lines
in all of football they drafted some
young guys a young running back a nice
wide receiver you still have t y hilton
um jack doyle at the tight end spot i
think the coach can make some noise i
think it's going to come down to to
their defense but overall i believe they
can make some noise yeah i'm rodney i'm
i'm you know i want to go off of that a
little bit like with their defense like
you talked about that to me you got good
you got it all fixed up there um is is
one of the big questions with them right
like difference-making players they got
deforest buckner you know the secondary
i think is a little underwhelming other
than more you know what is your outlook
on their defense we know they got those
stud linebackers but oh damn we lost
them
there he went ah
getting back go ahead keep going we'll
get him back yeah
i wondered why he got up and started
moving i guess he figured something was
going on maybe somebody's playing
fortnight in the house like you're used
to yeah there he is
you know what you got him i was i got
frozen my internet got frozen uh well i
mean you know i mean when you live in a
fortress it's hard to get an internet
you know uh connection at times but
chris
back to my phillip rivers point think
behind the offensive line between with
all the young weapons that they have ty
hilton i think this offense can be
really really good i think you know
after talking to one of my buddies over
in the coach they're really excited
about phillip rivers they feel like they
have a chance they like his leadership
they like his accuracy they like
everything that he brings and i think
he's going to be really good for him the
the defense though rodney to me yeah
like you said that's the question do you
think deforest buckner you know a guy
like xavier rhodes on the outside i
question their secondary a little bit i
don't look at that as a top-notch group
maybe but you think their defense can
can turn the corner this year and be a
little bit more of a force
i look at their defense i think their
defense could be solid you talk about
deforest buck i think he's a huge
addition he's a guy that reminds me of
an ex teammate of mine richard seymour a
big physical presence in the middle he's
really just you know just bringing that
toughness bringing that ability to play
inside and just that ability to put
pressure on a quarterback i think that
that was a big pick up for him
rodney we've got philip rivers in
indianapolis with a great offensive line
tom brady in tampa bay with a great set
of weapons around him receivers tight
ends etc what do you think is more
important and more desired for a
quarterback to have a great line or to
have a great set of receivers tight ends
and running backs
well that's difficult i think it depends
too on
who you are as a quarterback if you're a
quarterback that can't move
and you need some protection and it also
depends on the scheme i mean if you're
one of those teams that get the ball out
quick and you know you don't have to
worry about like tom brady over the last
20 years getting the ball out of his
hands quick you don't have to worry
about taking those hits but to me i
think it's weapons ultimately because if
you have weapons you know it's hard to
defend all those weapons across the
board
so you have to have some quarterbacks i
don't know ask chris what what would you
prefer that well no i mean you you said
it a little bit there's a lot of
depending factors i went with the
offensive line ultimately just because i
kind of just said you know if you're
saying
a great offense like you're saying might
be able to get away with it but the
normal offenses the middle of the road
average offenses in football uh i don't
know if they're creative enough to get
the ball out of the guy's hands and
things like that to where i go that's
why i'd rather have the pass protection
to let things develop down the field
have a little run game with that line up
there all those type of things but i i
hear your logic there too there's no i
don't think there's any right or wrong
answer i want to go back to the colts in
the south though a little rodney like
the south
is quietly one of the more intriguing
divisions in football in the afc
you know titans final four colts we're
talking about them we know dejean
watson's still there you know how do you
see it playing out down there
i look at the coaches probably being the
third best team in that division um
obviously tennessee had a huge year last
year i continue to look for them to get
better on offense i think they're going
to be still good on defense um the
houston texas man to me and i think mike
you brought up a very important point
yesterday i caught you guys show for
about five minutes but you talked about
a crutch for deshaun watson and that was
um deandre hopkins and i think you were
spot on i think now that he's gone they
got all these receivers these veteran
guys brandon cooks randall cobb i think
it's gonna make him a better more
complete quarterback because when he got
in trouble that was his crutch it was
deandre hopkins i'm going to find
deandre hopkins i'm going to hold the
ball to try to make a big play all the
time with deandre hopkins so i think he
was spot on yesterday when you talked
about that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports